mon père a dit que tu as fait un trajet complet jusqu'au
Kansas, mais pourquoi
j'ai déjà essayé de blesser mon père Je
n'ai plus jamais repris de basket-ball entendu que
tu es entraîneur de basket-ball me
détourne de l'esprit d'autres choses
vérifie que nous avons un code de  conduite [ __ ]
j'ai le sentiment que cette équipe n'est pas aussi
mauvaise que son bilan
je veux juste que tu sois heureux à nouveau
ne sous-estime pas l'impact que tu peux
avoir sur eux mec euh Kazuko juste pas je
vais entendre ta voix oui ou  non oui
tu es nerveux je comprends
mais je te promets qu'ils ne sont pas une meilleure
équipe
tu n'aimes pas toujours te faire
renverser pour te relever ils
ne savent pas ce que c'est que de te battre
[Musique]